repasamos los titulares internacionales
en revistas de prensa con rosa pérez más
de euros afiliaciones para ti feliz
inicio de semana vamos a hablar por
supuesto del clima comenzamos con al
yazira urgencia climática los eventos
meteorológicos más extremos de estos 21
que me hago eso es raúl precisamente
este artículo de al yazira lo que hace
es un recopilatorio de distintos eventos
extremos meteorológicos que sea que han
sucedido solamente en lo que llevamos de
2021 por que es impactante no ver la
tendencia más allá pues de estos eventos
de forma aislada y entre otras cosas
porque no vamos a tener tiempo de
repasar los todos los que menciona pues
señala por ejemplo las fuertes nevadas
en madrid en enero que según la agencia
meteorológica española fueron causadas
por la histórica tormenta que las
precedió también señala los récords de
bajas temperaturas en texas en eeuu que
recordemos causaron decenas de muertes y
también cortes de electricidad muy
prolongados en febrero por otras por
otro lado también esta histórica
tormenta de arena en china que también
empeoró los niveles de polución y la
calidad del aire también señala
recordemos los récords de temperaturas
pero en este caso de altas temperaturas
que tuvieron lugar en canadá y causaron
cientos de muertes según las autoridades
las inundaciones en alemania por otro
lado los incendios devastadores en el
mediterráneo también en eeuu recordemos
que en california el vix y fire ardió
durante meses o sin ir más lejos también
en la tormenta que se acabó convirtiendo
una tormenta tropical a edad que también
devastó parte de la costa este del mismo
país de eeuu hablamos del país pero del
diario español rosa porque tiene un
artículo muy interesante los puntos que
más se han calentado en américa con el
cambio climático este artículo hizo
jorge galindo eso es este artículo lo
que señala es que en el continente
americano las zonas que se han visto más
afectadas por el aumento de la
temperatura global es sobre todo la zona
de norte américa y la costa oeste y hay
perdón en la costa atlántica del todo el
continente de la costa este el caso y
señala que sin embargo el aumento en
norteamérica se dio hasta los años 90
este aumento tan acentuado y que desde
entonces es más bien américa del sur
donde este aumento está siendo más
marcado y vemos en este gráfico pues la
lista la clasificación por países y
vemos como aumentado en canadá y en eeuu
de forma muy clara respecto al resto del
continente vemos como bolivia está en la
cola y señala que precisamente este
aumento tan acentuado en canadá y eeuu
se debe entre otras cosas en que estos
países han basado su modelo de
desarrollo y de riqueza en una
explotación muy fuerte de los
combustibles fósiles pero se deje
precisamente en estar con 26 de glasgow
se va a discutir el peso que debe cargar
cada país en la lucha para frenar este
calentamiento global pero seguimos
entonces analizando y viendo otros
diarios página 2 en argentina el cambio
climático impacta más en la niñez y la
adolescencia más pobre maría daniela ya
carl hizo este artículo rosa si este
artículo se basa en un estudio realizado
juntamente entre la organización mundial
de la salud the lancet o unicef esta
agencia de las naciones unidas para la
infancia y lo que señala es que si bien
es cierto que en el cambio climático en
parte estamos todos en el mismo barco
pues nuestras condiciones materiales no
las desigualdades también afectan a la
vulnerabilidad que sufrimos frente a
estos cambios y estos grandes eventos
extremos meteorológicos y por ejemplo
uno de los miembros de los realizadores
de este estudio el médico raúl mercè
señala a página/12 el cambio climático
la degradación ecológica las migraciones
forzadas la desigualdad las prácticas
comerciales depredadoras amenazan la
salud y el futuro de los niños
particularmente de los más pobres y este
informe por lo tanto ha servido de base
para una iniciativa que se llama cap
2030 y que lo que pretende exponer la
infancia y la adolescencia en el centro
de las políticas públicas para intentar
frenar la degradación de las condiciones
de vida de los niños alrededor del
planeta y finalizamos la revista de
prensa de hoy con la selección de
fotografías de la isla de la palma
tomadas por el fotógrafo emilio
morenatti
associated tras eso es recordemos que
emilio morenatti es un fotógrafo bueno y
reconocido internacionalmente entre
otras cosas ganó el premio pulitzer por
su cobertura de la pandemia en españa de
cómo afectó a la población mayor en ese
país europeo y estas imágenes no pues se
muestran como parte de la isla de la
palma está cubierta completamente por
cenizas de esta erupción volcánica del
volcán cumbre vieja que recordemos se
inició el 19 de septiembre y sigue
activa no hay precisamente es impactante
este contraste entre la actividad
volcánica y esta calma no digamos de la
estas imágenes que evocan más bien eso
como pascal de la paz después de la
tormenta pero claro pero vemos aquí pues
grandes plantaciones de bananos a casas
y es que según en la última
actualización de las autoridades
españolas de hoy mismo dos mil 574
edificado han sido devastadas por la
lava y 975 hectáreas mientras que esta
mañana se han registrado ya cerca de 70
terremotos en la isla pues rosa entonces
muchísimas gracias por toda esta
información nos vemos mañana con más
revista de prensa ahora vamos a empezar
a analizar nuestro tema del día con
estos invitados rosa
[Música]